[Music]
they have challenged me to get involved
especially since i was so negative uh
with the conversation cards so you've
got some of them
so this is how this works this is how
this works i'm just pulling up so
imagine me and you are getting chips in
queso or just having a conversation from
a couple of 10 million people
what's one word or phrase that's way
overused
literally literally oh literally is the
worst literally
rachel cruz literally everything
literally the word i can't stand is the
word awesome and i say it
it sounds like an old like sad my past
teacher our pastor friend has a fit
about that because he says that word
should be reserved for god
and i say it all the time too like i'm
some kind of surfer boy or something
well it sounds like an old dude youth
minister in shorts like you're awesome
yeah and we're like we shouldn't be
saying this but yeah it's yeah it's a
great word but it is yeah overused all
right what physical activity well dave's
out on that one what physical activity
or i'm just being ugly today
physical activity or something whooping
on john this is could you disagree with
pretty much anyone at say it again what
physical activity or sport could you
defeat pretty much anyone at
none
um
but i am um in the top one percent on a
water ski or barefooting you are
incredible at that so um and i'm 61
years old and still barefoot so
that's you know that that does put you
up there i saw you get off the back of
the boat
i couldn't believe if i hadn't been
there i would have thought they were
exaggerating when you were on the back
of the boat and then you took the key
this the rope and threw it into the back
of the boat and you had
we were surfing that surf everybody
surfs where'd you surf it i've never
seen that well it's it's really
impressive when you've never seen it but
it's not that hard so i just saw you on
some sort of device behind the boat
nothing was pulling you and you were
still following the boat that's that's
surfing yeah that's that lots of people
do that that a lot of people are gonna
be going john that's not that impressive
but um i thought but yeah we've been
doing it since nobody was doing it
that's for sure we started doing it we
had to get our own little board and
figure it out and then it suddenly
became a thing now they build boats just
to do that
what's a movie or tv show that you're
ashamed to admit you watched downton
abbey
lost my man card on that one do you like
every episode
yeah lost my man card on that one for
sure
oh man without hesitation boom just like
that you liked it oh i loved it yeah
completely lost my man carter
ah the music just ding ding ding ding
ding the whole thing
if you can't see if you're listening on
podcast davis actually hugging himself
right
when he just said that no his arms are
crossed in a bad body language position
he's not he's hugging himself all right
what's the strangest thing you know
about your family history
uh
you can repeat on the air yeah really um
well on the one side i had a group that
had my two great grandfathers were both
preachers one of them was a circuit
riding preacher
and on the back of a mule went around
all throughout the south and i've got
his bible from the 1800s that he carried
in the saddlebags wow that's on the one
side on the other side
someone murdered one of the ramses
and uh the the widow was pregnant
and when the baby was born 18 years
later she handed him
her his dad's gun and said the guys in
montana go kill him and he did
[Laughter]
so so you come back
one side and we got this other thing on
the other side so i don't know yeah it's
it's wild
so america if you don't think genetics
are a players later hillbilly will send
you your the son
of your father to that you killed to
come kill you i mean this is that's
that's hillbilly stuff right there man
wow
that's fantastic dave
i'm not usually speechless that's
incredible and i'm looking at the
manifestation of that right now
and you've been making fun of me just
keep this
i'm quiet now yeah i just want to tell
you that you're looking great
looking kind of young you're looking
younger than i've ever seen you yeah you
look fast too like you can just run fast
that's incredible
questions for humans everybody man you
get a group of people around the table
and it's fun i have to admit uh yeah
it's pretty cool you dig up something
and get to talking about something other
than just stupid stuff tell your friends
that you cannot talk about covet and not
talk about whatever there's not a
coveted question or a politics question
in this thank you jesus not in this debt
no vaccine questions no thank you jesus
we did think about coming up with
another deck on ending friendships and
it's just going to be all
stuff
when you answer this question
trump is the greatest ever true or false
go
[Laughter]
people who don't get vaccines are evil
go like we're just gonna we're gonna
clear your friend deck for you
we're gonna sell that deck at a hundred
dollars a piece separate the sheep and
the goats right here y'all can just move